do you know what I have here that would
be a tiny little box that's roughly half
the size of a ps4 roughly yeah more
specifically it's the Alienware elf
okay yeah so this was their steam
machine right but now it's just a
machine this is a machine machine yeah I
mean most people would say it's a tiny
PC from Alienware that plays steam games
and you know it's pretty inexpensive
what Alienware says is that this is a
console and so I was curious how you
felt about that because that's a console
that's a console that's a PC is it this
isn't even bigger PC oh god oh Jesus
all right but the fact the fact is right
I mean people usually think of consoles
because they're small devices that hook
up to your TV you play games with a
controller predominantly hmm it's the
same thing with this yeah would you call
this console I mean no I wouldn't cause
like when I think of console I think of
like a closed ecosystem that's run by
one platform holder and everything is
very specific to them this is a PC it's
a tiny PC but like pcs difficut and
smaller and smaller for years now so the
only thing that differentiates between
these two things is the closed ecosystem
oh yeah I would probably say so um I
mean what do you think is that I mean I
kind of see that the lines have been
blurred at this point like yeah the
ecosystems are different but let's be
honest both of these things play games
even user controller hook it up to your
TV they're both easy to use this has a
user interface when you turn it on you
have a mouse and keyboard hooked up you
can go into desktop but with just a
controller it goes into alien where's
proprietary user interface controller
everything with a controller and and if
you actually want to get specific about
it it really only supports steam whoo
that controller interface we try to do
origin or you play you have to actually
use a mouse and keyboard so okay in a
sense if you want to consider a steam
machine still that's still sort of a
closed ecosystem just with the
possibility to open it up once you do I
guess turn it into a PC so maybe in that
sense it's a mix of console and PC but
but a lien where is pretty Stern about
the fact
this is a console it's like they're
trying to break into that market but I
don't know if just calling it that is
going to be enough to convince console
users that this is something they should
be interested right well I guess so at
this point in time like why does
somebody choose a console over a piece a
PC these days do they do it for
simplicity do they do it for convenience
versus exclusives yeah that's true brand
loyalty yeah I guess probably the
biggest differentiator is price right
yeah
consoles you still get a relatively
subsidized device compared to like a PC
like this Aurora which how much does
that retail for too much money too much
too much of my money I couldn't afford
it's very expensive this guy starts at
just around five hundred and fifty
dollars and that includes a Intel Core
i3 a two gigahertz four gigs of ddr3 RAM
and the equivalent of a souped-up gtx
860m mobile GPU it's pretty good it's
really not bad and actually what you can
do is you can open this up you can
install a new CPU that's not hardwired
to the motherboard so you can just pop
off the thing of the fan and the little
gate and they didn't put any one you can
upgrade the brand you can upgrade
upgrade the hard drive to an SSD the
only thing you can't really change is
the GPU which is hardwired onto the
motherboard okay yeah but you do have
access to I mean thousands of additional
games right that you wouldn't get with a
console so that is another thing worth
considering kind of like the Xbox one it
also has HDMI in and out so you can pass
through your cable box which you know
that's a pretty minor feature in my book
but uh but yeah I think it's curious
that Alienware is is so adamant to call
this a console because to me it's it's
sort of hard to define it one way or the
other
yes it's nebulous at this point yeah I
mean at a certain point you're just
arguing semantics right yeah eventually
like the lines have blurred so much that
it's hard to really even tell the
difference anymore at a certain point
all you have to really consider is just
value to the consumer like how do games
run on this compared to like a similar
game on the ps4 so just with the stock
base Hardware I decided to throw shadows
of Mordor on there and run it at full
blast at 1080p and there were moments
where it would sort of hiccup and run a
little slowly as you'd expect given the
hardware on the inside but I was pretty
surprised to see that it did run at a
really decent clip easily above 30
frames per second during a lot of
sequences
that included yes the opening intro
which is a small space but then also
when I broke out into the the first few
sectors of the game where you have a big
part of the earth like it's it's still
running really well so it's a pretty
powerful thing I a lien where's claiming
the base model can run as fast as before
at max settings which I have yet to test
but that's a really bold claim yeah I'm
kidding
but yeah we're going to be running this
you know through the gamut of tests
we're going to be throwing all the like
the new games at it and see what it can
do after crisis to beyond their max
settings that did not go above I think 8
frames per second glad that's not a
surprise well at the end of the end of
the day you can still watch youtube
videos of cats right oh yeah that's oh
yeah really what makes it a PC yeah